[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir un notage
français de plus au Liban et une fois
encore c'est un journaliste Roger ha 31
ans correspondant de RTL et de la radio
belge à Beyrouth il a été enlevé ce
matin tout près de son domicile dans le
secteur ouest de la capitale Roger ha
était l'un des derniers journalistes
français à être resté en secteur
musulman aucune organisation n'a
revendiquer cet enlèvement pour le
moment cela dit plusieurs témoignages
permettent de reconstituer la façon dont
s'est déroulé Francine RM Roger ha
quelques minutes avant son enlèvement
avait assisté à une conférence de presse
donnée par l'émissaire de l'archevcc de
Canterbury dans un hôtel de beyouth
ouest Terry white arrivé hier dans la
capitale libanaise avec l'espoir
d'obtenir de nouvelles libération
d'otagees occidentaux Roger haw faisait
partie de ce groupe de photographes
après la conférence de presse il passera
prendre quelques affaires dans son
appartement un de ses amis journalistes
l'attendait en bas de son immeuble le
type à la calach m'a pris par la veste
il m'a dit en anglais suis-moi suis-moi
et moi j'ai commencé à à me débattre et
j'ai vu Roger qui était de l'autre côté
de qui était dans le hall de son
immeuble mais le hall de son immeuble
ferme par une grille et il a vu et je je
me débattais je frappais le type qui av
une calache je lu disais sors pas sors
pas ne bouge pas sors pas et il a pas
compris je crois qu'il a pas compris ce
qui s'est passé parce que lui il criait
il disit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites qu'est-ce
que vous faites et il est sorti il a
ouvert la grille il est sorti à ce
moment-là l'autre type lui a mis le P
sur la tête et j'ai vu qu'il se
débattait aussi depuis 3 ans Roger ha
était à beéroutth le correspondant de
RTL du journal Lacroix et de l'agence
Gamma il ne voulait pas quitter le
secteur musulman et se disait rassuré
par les récentes libérations d'otage
français ce qui ne l'empêchait pas
d'être conscient du danger de plus en
plus on peut assimiler le le métier de
reporter à à celui de diplommate qu'on
cour de plus en plus des risques et
avant on avait on avait disons
l'habitude de chasser d'être plutôt le
le chasseur c'était surtout le reporte
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on devient
un petit peu un gibier son enlèvement
visiblement a été minutieusement préparé
projet hoc est désormais le 6e français
à être détenu à otage au
Liban à Paris le ministère des Affaires
étrangères a publié